good evening everyone
time being the first is not easy but I'm
excited I'm joy Pena global diversity
and inclusion leader at Electronic Arts
I will admit that I'm partially excited
because I have a four and a half month
old at home so to be out here dressed
and dolled up can you make me feel like
superwoman right now but I'm also
excited because I live for this
I love women connecting women with women
other women I love sisterhood I I always
wanted a sister tribe to be frank
since I was young but I only had a
brother who was 21 years older than me
so I tucked and clay grew up was an only
child my mother on the other hand had
nine sisters and four brothers yeah that
deserves a stage at a later time for
storytelling but because she grew up and
there being 10 of them right 10 women
she always seemed to seek out sisterhood
no matter the environment whether it was
work Church the neighborhood and so I
grew up with women around all the time
and many of them not just those who are
my biological aunts just women that she
had come to connect with I called my
auntie's so it was kind of an
unintentional gift to understand the
power of sisterhood women always in the
house laughing and talking connecting on
the couch or and the Kitchener on the
phone and I think my mother for that I
began to then seek that out in our
environment myself she also took on
someone who was somewhat of a daughter
second daughter to her ten years older
than me who really became like a big
sister to me by the name of Michelle and
she's influenced me tremendously to this
day and so listen there are countless
names that are of women that I could
tell you about who have influenced me in
very many different circumstances of my
life but you won't know their names
there is the name of one woman though
that I hope you know who left a lasting
impression on me and that's Hoda Kotb so
hopefully you know Jota hood is right
co-anchor of the Today Show well when I
graduated from college I was a part of
the NBC page program one year program
where you really cut your teeth and get
to know the business and so I did that
and I had a 12-week assignment at
Dateline NBC and I was for the most part
answer
phones offering help on research and
different projects and I had heard that
Hoda and a few producers were working on
a story about Whitney Houston and see
Whitney was like auntie in my head you
know there's some of these women that
I'm like a you know she's auntie Whitney
and so I thought I have to work on this
project how am I going to work on this I
started to offer just help and support
and Hoda welcomed it she even gave me
time to spend in her office to hear
about her journey and for her to counsel
my career and to women producers as well
who open the door for me anyway the show
aired that was about Whitney I was a
Friday night and I told all my friends
you have to watch this you'll never know
that I worked on it but you know I work
I I did I gave time to this project so a
Friday night it aired as the credits
rolling up at the end there's my name as
an assistant producer and this is a year
after graduating from college and I was
blown away I was on my tiny and you know
my tiny apartment in New York on the
floor literally floored you would have
thought I'd gotten an Oscar nomination
it was such a moment for me but it loves
such an impression on me and to actually
add to that not expecting kind of credit
for this work as a recent grad in the
next week Hoda sent me flowers just to
say thank you I know right just to say
thank you for contributing to this piece
and I was really blown away by that and
I'm sure she sent flowers to everybody
and I'm sure she would not remember my
name but it left such a maybe she does I
hear her at her daughter's middle name
is joy
I don't know maybe I left an impression
on her I did but I am so happy that she
we had that experience because it's
stuck with me and I'd like to say that
every experience that I've had with with
women and leaders has been wonderful
right and I and obviously I'm not
someone who subscribes to this myth that
women don't support women because I
think secure confident driven focused
women do support each other and that's
been my experience right we do do but I
you know will share that I've also had
an experience where I didn't feel so
supported and it left us much of a
lasting impact on me and so when I moved
from New York to California about 12
years ago I also transitioned from
television production into HR to really
do much of what I'm talking about
opening the door for others and their
opportunities and there was a woman I'd
heard about who is really successful in
the field that I'm in and had become
really you know well-known for it so we
had had the opportunity to meet at an
industry event and the person who
introduced us said you know the
conversation was great until he kind of
said joy reminds me of a younger version
of you and the conversation went cold at
that moment and I and that would have
been fine you know for whatever the
reasons were but I bumped into this this
person had a few industry events later
that year and in mutual circles folks
would try to introduce us and that would
go kind of like this so so and so you
know joy Kenya right you've met her and
she would say did we know did that
happen a few times and I think I'm
pretty memorable but apparently you know
she did not want to acknowledge me right
and that really crushed me someone who
had looked up to and and really had
hoped to connect with and listen I've
matured professionally to understand
that and I don't want to demonize her to
understand that she maybe was having a
bad day or a few bad days
ah bad season but I
I learned not to idolize people we're
all human
but I also didn't want to be the woman
who doesn't see another woman right I
really really it birthed in me a passion
to do the opposite and so I share both
of those experiences because they were
that passion in me to connect women and
since then when have even been in
between jobs I've hosted a few workshops
for women on how to network and even had
hosted brunches and happy hours for
women in my network out in Los Angeles
about 30 to 50 women assistant to
c-suite level and have heard of so many
opportunities that have come out of
those connections and so you know you
don't have to host a brunch or a happy
hour but I want to encourage you to look
around you you know who haven't you seen
who haven't you acknowledged who can you
connect with there's so much power in
that quite honestly and you've probably
heard this saying I don't think one
candle loses its flame by lighting
another so if we all encourage each
other support each other and champion
one another I think that that's a pretty
powerful light that we create together
so you know I really want to leave you
with this and I'm shocked that I have
two minutes left because when they told
me ten minutes I thought oh my gosh I
could tell you a story for an hour
really treating this like you're on my
couch or in my kitchen but what I want
to leave you with this is as you rise
women as you rise then to because I see
a few good men in the house which is
awesome as you rise I encourage you to
reach back someone is watching you
someone is reach back lift another
sister up you know open the door for an
opportunity even if it wasn't open for
you open the door for someone else with
encouragement with advice with
experience with knowledge
reach back as you rise reach out reach
out to your peers they don't even have
to be in your industry or your
profession I honestly some of my
greatest sources of inspiration actually
there's a particular group that I
affectionately call my lady loves there
a ton of us who graduated from college
together we are from all different
fields and industries and
area cities across the country and I
have girlfriends out in California as
well and let me tell you those group
chats are the best height man a girl can
use before a presentation and even today
I mean they're there you know in their
cities waiting to hear how this goes and
so you know there's such power in that
and that's that's what I encourage you
to do reach out as you rise finally I
would hope that you also reach up and if
there is not a Hoda Kotb to reach back
at you if you're blazing the trail then
who are the aunties in your head that
you can also think about and that you've
been inspired by that have amazed you in
the ways that they've blaze their own
trails be inspired by them as well and
so I wish you great success but I also
wish you great sisterhood along the
journey thank you
[Applause]